we're told we want to find the zeros of
this polynomial and they give us the
polynomial right over here and it's in
factored form and they say plot all the
zeros or the x-intercepts of the
polynomial in the interactive graph and
so this is a screenshot from khan
academy if you're doing it on khan
academy you would click where the zeros
are to plot the zeros but i'm just going
to draw it in so pause this video and
see if you can have a go at this before
we work on this together
all right now let's work on this
together so the zeros are the x values
that make our polynomial equal to zero
so another way to think about it is for
what x values are p of x equal to zero
those would be the zeros so essentially
we have to say hey what x values would
make 2x times 2x plus 3
times x minus 2 because this is p of x
what x values would make this equal to
0.
well as we've talked about in previous
videos if you take the product of things
and that equals zero if any one of those
things equals zero at least one of those
things equals zero would make the whole
product equal zero so for example if 2x
is equal to zero it would make the whole
thing zero so 2x could be equal to 0 and
if 2x is equal to 0 that means x is
equal to 0. and you could try that out
if x is equal to 0 this part right over
here is going to be equal to 0. it
doesn't matter what these other two
things are 0 times something some
something is going to be equal to 0.
and then you could say well well maybe
2x plus 3 is equal to 0. so we could
just write that 2x plus 3 is equal to 0.
and if that were to true what would x or
what would x have to be in order to make
that true subtract 3 from both sides 2x
would have to be equal to negative 3 or
x would be equal to negative 3 halves so
this is another x value that would make
the whole thing zero because if x is
equal to negative 3 halves then 2x plus
3 is equal to 0 you take a 0 times
whatever this is and whatever that is
you're going to get 0.
and then last but not least
x minus 2 could be equal to 0. that
would make the whole product equal to 0.
so what x value makes x minus 2 equals 0
we'll add 2 to both sides and you would
get x is equal to 2. if x equals 2 that
equals 0. doesn't matter what these
other two things are 0 times something
times something is going to be equal to
0. so just like that we have the zeros
of our polynomial
and the reason why they have
x-intercepts in parentheses here is
that's where the graph of p of x if you
say y equals p of x that's where it
would intersect the x axis and that's
because that's where our polynomial is
equal to zero
so let's see we have x equals zero
which is right over there once again if
you were doing this on khan academy you
would just click right over there and it
would put a little dot there
we have x is equal to negative three
halves which is the same thing as
negative one and a half so that's right
over there
and then we have x equals 2 which is
right over there so those are the x
intercepts or the zeros of that
polynomial
now this is useful in life because you
could use it to graph a function i don't
know exactly what this function looks
like maybe it looks something like this
maybe it looks something like
this we would have to try out a few
other values to get a sense of that but
we at least know where it's intersecting
the x-axis it's at the zeros